So this is officially my second fall date night outfit.
I went out last night.
I wore these both times because I thought they were gonna be a gimmick.
These, like,
fleece line tights looking leggings.
They are not. I love these things.
I'm gonna wear them all the time apparently.
But I'm getting ready to go out with my hubby
and now I'm gonna be toasty warm.
so I'm going with like this headband and some matching earrings.
And then I need to pick out the purse.
I've got this one by Fable England.
Really cute. Very much color matches the top.
And then we just have a vintage Louis Vuitton.
So we're gonna have to find out.
I decided to go with the fable England
because I think it just ties all the colors together.
And that's full day night.